wasn't born in Hawaii he lived there in
San Francisco but I did a lot of my
growing up there so yeah so it was it
was amazing I don't know I don't think
no he told me
[Laughter]
for years I've always said well when we
were there you gave me a big speech like
this is my land I started
[Music]
now all of a sudden San Fran I was San
Fran then I transferred he gave me a
very like spiritual speech about how it
all started
this is a cliff where I was born
this is the problem
you'll try to be respectful Hawaii was
beautiful beautiful uh you know
Mountainside and lushness and and we
shot in this beautiful place called
kualoa Ranch where uh Jurassic Park the
original Jurassic Park was shot and the
ones after that as well and it was just
amazing but you didn't he hated it no no
this is the problem I didn't like it at
all I mean outside of the the spiritual
grounds that you took me to and I swore
you even sung a song
we'll talk about it later
you were like
proper Olympic medals wow Marion have
you seen an Olympics I actually did yeah
or was it French people beat you oh the
French got gold
is there anyone in Ireland who hasn't
seen those medals they look like being
around the block those medals they're
fairly tackled yeah and of course as um
Michael down in Killarney word must have
reached you of the adult oh for sure I
mean I wasn't in Killarney at the time
but uh everybody knew about it that's
for sure yeah yeah and Marion watching
that clip on that could you understand
the accents nothing not a word
I understood since
[Laughter]
the people people loved the interviews
you did at during the Olympics but like
you guys knew you were being funny while
you were doing the interface
I don't know
I think it's funny because they were
being themselves yeah well to be fair we
weren't true
yeah and just yeah you just trying to
happen that way like you did seem very
happy to be in Rio I was quite serious
about the whole situation at all every
time we talked it's the truth like yeah
I'm saying like people ask us these
questions all the time after race as it
just so happened they put a camera in
front of us in real
you want a silver medal so suddenly
everyone was interested but this is but
the great thing is this is like Ireland
has never won any medal in rowing before
have they well not Olympics no they have
a few world championship titles all
right what is the first Olympic medal
yeah
and the interview where you talked about
your approach to the race
uh the phrases you used in that so
explain to people what you what you said
in that do you know about going A to B
faster you can yeah yeah this is a
fairly simple sport like
it
too complicated life your man says
[Laughter]
this is based on your life I mean this
is things yeah but I mean
Loosely Graham you know when things like
isn't the washing machine that happened
to you what the the washing you were
very hungover oh
tell Jody Foster that story
all those stories are really cool though
Graham
when I was teaching
this is what this show is based on I I
went home one weekend and I was in my
30s I was probably 33 years of age I
went home to see my mother
and then I went back and while I was at
home my mother did my washing for me
because I was only 33.
back on the on the Sunday night I got
really drunk uh and then I went for a
curry
and then the next day I went into school
I'm gonna I went into school and it was
a school in Slough and it was quite a
rough school but they had a really
brilliant hearing impaired department so
they were hearing impaired kids who uh
you know struggled they were they were
really looked after in the school anyway
I was really hungover I went there and
about break time I felt really
uncomfortable I thought something's not
right you know so I went to the toilet
and I pulled my trousers down and some
of my mother's knickers have got
I got mixed up in the washing and I was
wearing my mother's underwear
and I went oh God no oh I remember going
are you loser this is such a low point
you [__] loser
and then the curry and the boot the
curry and the booze kicked in from the
night before so I I did like a fecal
Jackson Pollock
laughs
and I started
I started going oh God not this not this
as well oh Jesus so I cleaned myself up
and I pulled my mother's pants back up
and I went back into the um classroom
and I saw one of the hearing impact kids
just looking at me like this and that's
when I remembered that my I had a
microphone directly
there it is
a lot of youngsters they you know they
Revere you so they they look to you the
other thing you inspire is Impressions
people doing impressions now when people
do impressions of you is it like sort of
nails on a chalkboard or do you kind of
enjoy it
no I I kind of enjoy it especially if
they do it well
uh so no I I it's great it's
I love it I only asked
no because because of Any hiddlestone is
watching will know uh Tom Hiddleston
does impressive you do right pressure so
who's in your Cannon it's a it's a
expression of admiration just to be
clear
um so I do I do uh impressions of people
that I I admire and I sort of listen to
them I get the first time I did an
impression
um that anyone was aware of I was just
telling a story about midnight in Paris
the Woody Allen film I was in and how I
never read the whole script and I and I
thought it was set in the 20s and um I
turned up and I bombed his own Wilson
who didn't look like he was in the 20s
at all
and uh and I said to him I said so wait
hang on who are you playing because I'm
playing F Scott Fitzgerald and I know
Corey stalls playing Ernest Hemingway
and we're all playing figures of history
and he went oh no no no no no no I'm
from now I go back
machine
you know it's kind of cool and it's kind
of Woody and you just kind of it's kind
of Awesome
[Applause]
I've been made to do impressions of my
fellow Avengers
um uh I think everyone does an
impression of Christopher Walken because
he's just he's such an easy kind of you
know
I feel like what this show needs
is more cowbell
depends on what
you like me to say
basically there's no
punctuation
anything that comes out of my mouth
I like that
I know whole pages of heat you surprised
me
so I there's this there's a scene in the
middle of the film which you'll be
familiar with you were there
the one person you don't need to explain
it
he remembers
in the middle of the film which is
because because Al Pacino and Robert De
Niro
who's that I'm sorry buddy they're
separated like a great Thriller they're
separated from for the entire film and
they meet twice once at the end or once
in the middle and it takes place at a
restaurant La it's a great scene it's
one of the great pieces of screen acting
you can hope to watch there it is it
says a picture of it it's like a it's a
mutual recognition of each other anyway
so there's a bit where they have like
they sit and have coffee and have tea
and talk about stuff I'm going on I
apologize
anyway so Al Pacino at one point Al
Pacino says this he goes uh
so
[Laughter]
we're sitting here like a couple of
regular fellas I mean uh
you do what you do
I do what I gotta do
if I'm there
I'm not gonna put you away
I won't like it
but if it's between you
and some poor bastard whose wife are
gonna turn into a widow
brother
you are going down
and then all right and then until then
and then it cut and then Michael Mann
Cuts back to the esteemed gentleman at
the end of the sofa
laughs
what if you do got me boxed in
I'm not gonna put you down
moving face to face
yeah
but I will not hesitate
not for a second
that's my
this is so this is So Meta
I feel like I've gone into a parallel
universe where um yeah
my favorite scene that was written
before not because of doing it but just
my favorite scene written in the film
you know that that's a great piece of
rice yeah it feels like it plays in Two
in two singles in a way like yeah yeah
and it's it's like the most beautiful
game of tennis did you each do lots of
takes would you do lots of taxes yeah
that many take screen there I don't
think we did more than
five to eight or nine at the moment
maybe maybe less
they talk about your dreams and you talk
about your life
it's so good it's so great there's a bit
another bit where you go
we know you said you said sir he says uh
Pacino says
so you never wanted a regular type of
life and and uh
Bob may I call you Bob
Bob says um what's that barbecues and
ball games
I'm gonna kill you obviously your mother
loves you because you're her daughter
but she is actually a sort of a fan as
well you know it's not he's not quite
that it's um no she is oh goodness right
so my uh uh one day my mum came to set
on the Star Wars set uh and I was
getting this thing called cyber scans
which is where you stand in this kind of
loads of cameras and they kind of take
your form and put you into a computer
and make a toy or a some sort of
merchandise or your face on a cushion
um and so
I go off and do this and I come back and
mum's like I've made a great friend and
I'm like brilliant it's lovely excellent
and uh she's likes the merchandise you
know director of all of Star Wars or
something I'm like what else are you
very impressive
um and then before I know it what comes
in the post
um is loads of cushions
my face on it
my own mom would guess she gets to see
it a fair amount you know but apparently
it's not enough so yeah
kind of Blown Away how much merchandise
there is yes
it's just the beginning it was like the
pre-merchandise not even the real stuff
is out yet and my mum has all of it and
it doesn't know about the dog yet so
this is so weird I don't know is this in
your flat or her house right okay so
basically she thought it'd be really
funny if I came home and it was
everywhere in my room okay so this is
this is this is Amelia's actual bedroom
joke and then and then oh and then oh my
goodness we found the photo but it's not
like that now there is another reason
why I'm saying take a first date back to
that yeah
come on in
I'm just doing this little thing one I
don't have a CV I just have a bedroom
oh this is cool though so your mother a
big fan but Brad Pitt's also a great big
fan that was the best night of my life
yes
tell the story quickly
yeah
sheets slippers uh no yeah there was
this auction thing that happened and um
I don't they called me and said would
you you know do you want to do you want
to um auction something off like maybe
sort of an experience watching the show
with you or something and I was like
okay if it's lovely it's great for
charity yeah it'll be for some you know
some something yeah and it'll be fine
anyway so I get there and it's amazing
it'll be a good thing
um I get there and it's basically like
this it's basically it's the Oscars like
there's so many celebrities in this room
and I suddenly remember that I said that
I would auction something off and so the
fear grows so I was petrified absolutely
petrified and then um the person whose
table I was on is a friend and he was
being very kind and kind of put the
paddle up and I was like thanks very
much that's very sweet there will be
that and then someone else's paddle up
went up across the other side of the
room and I didn't really know and then
suddenly it was sort of becoming a a bit
of money and I was kind of thinking oh
she's absolutely mental and someone went
into Brad Pitt and I was like LOL
I'm gonna look over to the room and he's
got his paddle up Brad's paddle
no it's not quite well it didn't work
out because the person whose friend
who's was my friend I think it's
probably all set up the person who's who
was my friend ended up you know doing
the highest bid but um
can you look at a cartoon and come up
with a voice well like with Happy Feet I
I got to be like I played two different
characters initially three but then
there were that the one voice sounded
too familiar but when I got to play an
Argentinian penguin
penguin you know the guys the
Argentinian guys are going what do you
do you know you wanted
you looking at you know you want to look
at it don't be afraid of the flippers
I brought you some Pebbles there's some
bling baby you want some bling you know
you do
yes you're hot and you know I got a beak
that'll make you feel so good
and then you had like all the crazier
ones you know
talking about animation uh we got people
on our audience uh to draw cartoons of
themselves now I'm sensing I'm something
self-esteem issues
now oh no now God forbid when I asked to
see this woman in the audience but she
looks like this I am not you better not
put that up on a camera
I will be on you like [__] on Velcro
oh
yeah
false
fingers crossed fingers crossed okay
show the picture this is the lady
that her name is Jane Hayes Jane Hayes
now let's have a look at Jane In the
Flesh Jane Jane you're beautiful change
Jane you're not a gay black basketball
player
spare thought for Sally Jenkins and I
think her husband look at Sally
oh
with your funny little Terrier ears look
at you oh and for some reason you've
drawn a penis on your own face
why is she done that she's done a penis
with two tiny balls
those that I don't know there's two
upside down Bells
[Music]
is that your husband David that's you
yeah and are you are you naked as well
yeah what's up strange line yeah but
more importantly what's peeking out here
those are two balls going I'm down here
and why did you have an accordion for
now yes
yes
we were drunk
who else have I got oh actually see this
woman uh Stephanie Jack where's
Stephanie Jack
hello Stephanie Jack there's Stephanie
Jack In the Flesh and here she's in the
cartoon
[Applause]
thank you
DC a great Japanese anime character
needs to teach a lot to come to your
house
do you have a big eyes to come to your
house with the larger breasts open the
door with her nipples
Mr bouncing breast follow the bouncing
breasts
wow that's kind of one can I have this
one yes you can
been on the road for a while
why were you having the was it a deep
tissue massage you were having
where are you going with this queen
aren't you having a Turkish massage or
something I don't know what it has to do
with what we're talking about it's a
funny story tell it
I had an awful experience having a
Turkish massage
where
this guy's idea of massage was to like
take my one leg and and the other arm
and try and connect it
behind my back
and I was kind of like
you know like that and then I
well his belly went in my mouth
and you know when you get something
weird in your mouth and you're like if
you're eating something you go like you
send your brain sends your tongue to
figure out what it is
that a bone figure that out the tongue
goes in to figure it out my tongue was
like what is that
it's a hairy belly
sounds like you're heading off a
newspaper
now Emilia Clarke did you get to chat
with everyone backstage
um yeah kind of did you get to talk to
him yeah
[Music]
actually blushing
um yeah I just think you're Wicked
it's gave me two hours
baby in the corner are you returning the
favor do you watch Game of Thrones Matt
I've watched the first season and then I
kind of fell out of it and I tried to
watch it this year and I don't know
what's going on
there's lots of stuff going on so much
going on there is there really is
seen the good you've seen the good bits
you've seen the first season
[Music]
what is it it's season six now and it's
bigger than ever yeah whose life is that
it seriously sounds like a
chicken's going to stop because I
thought there was a mechanical fault
with something
human being
oh is it that man there all right well
I'm glad you're having a nice time
request from you though
um so would you would you be able to ask
me how I'm doing
[Applause]
hey you'll be gonna say no no yes uh
well since I you know haven't been up up
to speed on the show thank you yeah how
are you doing
yeah
there's some scenes where
they will play music maybe a bit of if
it's a wide shot and it's not like so
it's the closest we get to sort of kind
of sort of just sort of going for it in
one piece
um and they'll play music or something
and my temptation is always just to try
to make Dakota laugh so sometimes I'll
do things like when there's a moment
where I'm meant to you know orgasm I'll
be like
[Laughter]
a flight lands
people travel you know they collect
things postcards dolls and National
dress but you you collect
animals like like living animals
collect them I rescue them oh okay so
did you rescue anything when you were in
Sicilian Tuscany
not in that one but in the movie I did
right after in Bulgaria I I did okay and
I had I had promised my husband I was
gonna stop because at the time I had 10
dogs
five parrots I had alpacas horses
cats and by the way
one without a tail the other one without
a leg you know
and they always they find me they come
to me these animals which he doesn't
believe me but they do and I promise him
no more okay
we were up to 30 animals I I swore no
more and and I was there and a little
puppy who was abandoned and was gonna
die I won't tell you the sad story
because it's a comedic show and I'll
start crying he came to me and I
couldn't help and I picked him up
and his name is Ochoa after the the
goalie of the soccer team in Mexico it
was the World Cup and I took him and
then I was terrified how am I going to
explain this to my husband I promised I
promise and um so I came up with this
brilliant idea to pretend that I was
having an affair
no no with somebody to make him think I
was having Affair and at the end I would
say no it's not an affair I picked up a
dog and then he would feel better
so I left him a message you must call me
at this time we need to talk it's very
important and I never do that and this
time is okay what happened what happened
and I said listen I feel
so terrible I don't know how to say this
to you and I know this is not not going
to go down well and I'm really nervous
and please have mercy on me he has have
space and be understanding it's just
it's been so stressful and I'm so tired
and I was so lonely here for so many
days and you know you do crazy things
when you're in this stage and you said
to me oh please don't tell me you picked
up another dog
okay one of the things you can do is you
can conjure up people's fears yes okay
yes so you you're afraid of quite basic
things I'm afraid of like most things
like anything high risk I'm terrified of
but those are rational things okay
irrational is like spiders because but
they actually
um I become paralyzed when I when I have
a spider in my room really yeah I like
wish I were tougher than that but I'm
not okay now walk or flow were you
serious when you told us what your fear
is I mean it is it's a good fear it's I
think it's a founded fear I think it's a
founded fear it is tell us what it is
um I have a phobia of being chased
around with poop on a stick
[Laughter]
I'd say we've all got that fear
there's another one that goes not up for
that
it started when I was a kid
it was just weird parenting
for some reason kids thought it was
funny to stick a stick in dog poop and
Chase each other around with it
but that scared the crap out of me
because of the cleanliness problem of it
no spreading terms
[Laughter]
Jeremy Rana though yours is brilliantly
specific and I think without knowing it
I think we probably all share it we may
I don't know I I didn't have the the
fear when I was younger because we've
all we all go through this but it's when
a little child and I'm the oldest of
seven kids and I got a lot of little
Rugrats running around and they these
little roaches start losing their teeth
and they get a little Wiggly and they
like to show me like this little dagger
flipping in and out of their mouth and
like look everybody want to pull this
thing out I'm like get out of here
you're freaking me out
it's like her thumb it's just it's just
again you know
it just really kind of grosses me out
the cutest little thing on the planet
starts to do like the creepiest thing in
the planet and I'm like get out of here
it's like here tie the string to my
thing to the doorknob like get out of
here creep
animals
that's now
little ones running around flipping
their little fake their teeth falling
out look we all have this you know when
you have the dreams your teeth pull out
I don't know what it means anybody what
it means we get bigger ones
am I the only one
a friend of mine just had that dream too
yeah
not me what does that mean I don't know
share of money I think I think that's
what they do who has fear of money
maybe I'm just afraid of my teeth
[__] falling out
[Applause]
well I was gonna go with flying but I
think I'll go with um girls over 12.
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I
don't know what came over here
the last minute of my life I wouldn't
have predicted that
was it Mark Ruffalo you're not going to
believe what he said to me
he was bang on the money
very perceptive man
it was the Dora poem don't try and
justify it
do you know what I've always hated the
hulky [__]
angry
I my son said that to me the other day
when he was mad at me what you would
like him I always hated the Hulk I think
he's [__]
here's the thing uh Emma for you what is
the hold that the Spice Girls have over
you is this real
yes it's real and I just feel like I've
been talking more about the Spice Girls
on this press tour than I have about the
movie
I know I went
I really did but
but Mel B and what she really talking to
you was it a message no it was a video
message on an iPad and that made you cry
yes were you jet lag
[Applause]
you do understand because we're in the
UK I was I was a fiend I was obsessed
with the Spice Girls and they taught me
about girl power and I love them I think
they're fantastic and I'm what's the
song
there's so many Jamie there's so many
things
spice up your life every morning
yay there's so many and they're so
fantastic and today on the radio
um Mel C talked to me over Skype oh wow
so it's really very exciting okay who
would you say is your favorite Spice
Girl Emma Bunton Baby Spice she's your
favorite she's my favorite who's next
to that just a question all of the other
four
so Emma Bunton well Emma Bunton was the
one that I had blonde hair and bangs and
my name obviously is now Emma my name
was Emily but it was taken
when I became an actor
um and so now it's Emma and uh yeah I
just I love so give me this so so you
one gave you a video message and want to
talk to you on Skype yes but you're
telling me you've never met are you
gonna do something have you never said
are you gonna do something really have
you never met a spice girl I'm wait hold
on I have to mentally prepare myself
have you never met a Spice Girl not in
the flash okay now as you know as you
know as you know Emma it is very rare it
is very rare for more than one Spice
Girl
to appear together
for any reason at all
so they're not here
[Applause]
age sucks have you got a face but it is
because America is really so youth
obsessed I mean how and in the film you
show you know kind of that it is hard
for a woman of your age to get the job
it's beyond difficult the only jobs
really left now for women unless they
get friendly with people to do films but
the only jobs that are really
commercials I just thank God my I made
my yearly nut this year on a product
called girly which is for dry vagina and
it's uh
well anyone knows the Heartbreak of dry
vagina
[Applause]
Christmas
I was perfect for it
candles follow me home
thank you
[Applause]
three Jewish men are trying to rent my
uterus instead of going to Miami
but and this
thank God for these commercials there's
one called an uh Zestra is that come
here yet
women's Viagra has that happened here
yet it's women's Viagra and they have
this big discussion with me should they
make it in pill form this is honest to
God truth it was in the newspapers pill
form or cream because they didn't know
which would do better and they find a
side of these idiots will do it in cream
because if it's in pill form in a bar a
man can drop it in a woman's drink and
she won't know it but if you're in a bar
and a guy goes so where are you from
foreign
[Applause]
just here by the way you guys do know
each other outside of being back there
on a sofa I know John and I don't know
Steve
I see them on the Telly you know that's
not real I know I know and now it is
Jubilee weekend uh do you plans anybody
got plans I uh I didn't realize it was
Jubilee weekend but when I got here I
got in town a couple days ago and was
invited uh I guess to sit next to the
queen
um on the boat
that's amazing
I'm not gonna do it
he has been invited on the boat I'm
really confused now you're on the boat
no well
no
did you lie to him as well lie to me as
well yes John
it's a great story it really is I didn't
even know there was going to be a boat
and these two were thinking
do they not no it's just another thing
you don't have in common with the queen
yeah
Charlize Theron
delighted you're here for all sorts of
reasons I'm so happy to be I'm a huge
fan thank you
[Applause]
let's see in episode one The Doctors
thing yeah did that really happen yeah
my mum will kill me for telling this
because it was my uh uh our family
doctors and I
he'd been our family my doctor since I
was a child and but I went as an adult
because
I was there was something wrong with my
bum
why when you said bum you looked at me
directly in the eyes
stand on nerves
there was something but there was
something wrong with my
bun
[Laughter]
and I was a I said there's this thing
wrong with my bum and he went okay and I
went so
what'd you say he goes well
it'll probably be all right
I would really like it I'd like you to
just if you could make me feel better
about if I feel better that it will be
all right and he went it it'll probably
clear itself up and I said yeah but
is there any way I could be sure and he
went ah
you want me to put my finger up there
don't you
maybe maybe there's a reason but what is
the reason that you film it in the
school you used to teach in I think it's
therapy probably I'm in the actual
classroom where I talk because I was
just to keep the theme going a real
teacher for a long time yeah I talked
for yeah six years in the school that we
filming in the classroom that I'm going
Madding and I that's that's real that
was my classroom yeah but you didn't
foreign did you ever enjoy it was there
ever a moment when you thought I like
this I don't know okay
well I met some very nice people there
and
it was like you were nominated for
Teacher of the Year weren't you yes I
was great
yeah you know yes I've told this story
many times but
after the year is a very prestigious
award that's taken very seriously and
rightly by the hard-working teaching
community and my head teacher called me
in and he was wetting himself laughing
he couldn't stop laughing for the first
10 minutes and he went I went what why
have you called me here he goes you've
been numb
I've got this a teacher of the year
award you've been nominated
and I went oh okay and um it was by a
very sweet girl called Gemma I've
humiliated many times and it's a
six-page document that people have to
fill in for the reasons why you should
be nominated for Teacher of the Year it
was blank
aside from one sentence that she'd
written on it which was the reasons why
you think he should be teacher of the
year and she's written he's a well good
laugh and he don't make us do no work
why haven't we seen more of you two
together
it's a pairing it really is it's a match
made in heaven
now and Jackie Chan yes Jackie Chan uh
yes what I haven't done that once I'm
very soon I'm sitting on my hands I'm
going Jackie Chan I'm not doing that
because is it true that everyone just
goes Jackie Chan yeah
I really hate that you know whatever I
go you know in Europe America especially
the father by children
why nobody see Robert De Niro
that's a Robert De Niro wow Dustin
Hoffman
one day one day I hope people wow that's
a Jackie Chan yes yes that's Jackie Chan
do you enjoy things like that are they
fun or is it
just that business the the whole thing
about the those big uh events they call
them you know particularly in Canada's
red carpet things and do you enjoy them
do you like doing that no I can't do any
of that I really can't I've seen you I
did go well have you on a red can't but
I don't think so no have you I've seen
you show up at things not much to be
honest but you've you've done Posh
things you've you've mixed with royal
you've met the queen haven't you I have
met the queen yes I have met the queen
at um I think it was a uh one of those
receptions for people in the Arts you
should have been there Graham honey I
was you were overlooked yes okay do you
would be a dirty potting man
yeah I was you know what I was amazed at
with the queen and she's very tiny which
is something for me today because I'm
quite short and she moves as if on
Rollerblades she just slides up like
that there's no actual walkings guy I
don't know what's going on under there
she might be on casters
but as she comes to where you are the
group where you are uh for a start you
have to you have to tussle with that
whole idea of will you curtsy won't you
curse will you curtsy and I decided
before no look kurtzing it's no I'm not
going to bow down before Roy I'm not
going to and then immediately you do
too low
to be revolting and then of me I mean
and
then the queen says there was a group of
about four of us around her and she says
a very small thing you know so are you
enjoying the evening and everybody goes
like this
thank you
to the queen I think people are just
nervous are they eager to please don't
want to be beheaded or something I don't
know
I'm sure must think that she's a great
comedian or something
and
I was doing it
the queen yes I do you mean I was in
Hong Kong
I remember a long long time ago my anger
is so bad in that time I remember when
Queen raise your hand use your hand
otherwise you're standing here
and you're right what your Royal
Highness yes yeah and then I have to
remember your Royal Highness your right
highness Dennis well we've been playing
around oh Queen's coming Queen's coming
here
what should I say then I see the queen
stop stop stop so quick
oh okay then when she comes
yeah
she keep talking to me
my head is empty I don't know what she's
talking about
[Laughter]
you know honestly okay go away go away
leave me alone
of course I'm so happy just standing
here more than like a three minute five
minute but I just don't go away please
don't talk to me anymore I don't know
how to answer back
to America that's right it's Air New
Zealand that's right yes
they got whisked off on a little um
that's a hell of a service
all I got was a glass of champagne
can we say whisks on BBC One you can't
say whisked off oh that yeah
[Applause]
minutes in good night
now did you drive yourself here tonight
no no no I've got my driving license no
I'm still on driving me would you get in
the car with them
but now my husband is officially allowed
to drive yes I would get in a car with
him
he took 61 years but but I mean in terms
of teaching you did Noah before I was
too pissed to drive
okay fair enough go for my test another
go let's see a minute ago
no Mr Osborne come back another day I'm
not even getting in the cold again
walking around the test center with a
bottle of eye cream I pocket
did you learn an Emmanuel or an
automatic I could drive anything one of
a few drinks
is there anything you can use yet
is there anything that can go on BBC One
not yet you've just had a promotion it's
all DVD extras I know but it's a proper
Western I mean we see Tom Hanks gun
Toten which we rarely see well I don't
have I don't wear one I am given one
later on so it's not like you know I'm
not doing the root and tooting kind of
thing ever but I I I I I I ride a horse
and um I drive a wagon and I've
discovered so I'm not a I'm not a writer
per se but I did learn I I had a
fabulous got to know a fabulous hope
named wimpy who was my horse wimpy was
my husband and uh yeah I don't know if
anybody here is has written a lot or
belt as I recall Emily my darling how
are you how are you wonderful to see you
good to see you do you know what I'm
about to do a western like next January
I'm doing a six-part western and we were
just discussing how allergic I am to
horses and I do everything with a horse
you know I'm gonna be antihistamine up
to my eyeball
do you have to kiss the horse
isn't that what happens in Western to
make out with your hopes you you develop
an affection for those peace
every morning you throw your arms around
with you say how are you my garlic
little
chestnuts about you which you sort of
have to do because I have a feeling that
horses honestly they would much rather
live in a world without human beings
climbing on top of them and they know
that you climb on their back that you're
terrible at riding like I mean I've been
learning right now I'm I'm in London now
rehearsing for it and I go riding three
times a week and every time they give me
a different horse to see you know how
you fare oh with one that's more
sprinkly or one that's less of a Ferrari
and I got on one the other day called
Rusty oh my God I almost took off with
me it was terrifying I couldn't walk the
next day Rusty did me in
[Applause]
wow is that the name of the film
how did you know Sir Patrick Stewart and
you don't really use the Sarah much do
you
uh
what should I sorry should I have been
calling you no I shouldn't am I supposed
to no okay but but no do you I take my
lead from Sir Ian I whom we've both
shared some time with yes and uh he is
he is so phlegmatic about all of that
and and I just you know it's a great
honor but it's not something that I need
to press when you bump into another sir
when you're out and about do you then do
you do you call each other
[Applause]
so how do you become a sir
um Patrick how
well you know it's a case of um
I got mine on the Queen's birthday
honors but you have reminded me that I
did have a sir encounter only a few
weeks ago in Los Angeles a rather fancy
in fact extremely fancy restaurant tell
them what it is because they'll know
um it was the uh the the the Tower bar
uh no yeah guys
[Applause]
keep going you keep going keep going
okay wow no the towel bar is the spot I
got a feeling this isn't gonna work out
so we had four of us were seated at a
table about 15 minutes later into the
restaurant walks Sir Paul McCartney wow
good now Paul and I have a very slender
relationship but it's lasted decades I
first encountered him in
1964. no when his girlfriend Jane Asher
then told him that I loved Aston Martins
I was driving a battered old Ford but
Aston Martin's were my dream car she
told him this and one night yeah we knew
he was seeing the show there was a knock
on my door and I said yeah come in I'm
there in my underwear you know like as
usual
come in I'm in my pants
I'm ready for you
come in and the door open and standing
there was Paul McCartney who I had never
met before and this was 1964. and uh he
said Jane says that you like Aston
Martin's here drive this wow and he
tossed a bunch of keys and it was an ass
it was his
[Applause]
we are
it's a legend
I am feeling less and less good keep
going keep going you're in there so Paul
McCartney's coming in the 60s and uh uh
he sees me and comes over and uh I stand
up and say hi and we have a big hug in
the restaurant and I'm very much aware
that there's all the tables are full on
this kind of thing and we talked for
five or six minutes and he goes and sits
down five minutes go by and into the
restaurant
walks a Ringo Starr I swear to you I'm
not making this one were they together
they were they were oh they were at the
same table they were the same yes
um well uh we uh at the tower
I am expecting so many free meals
I have to go and Paul stands up to say
goodbye and we have a hug and this we
have a hug he says into my ear
do you know Ringo
I've never met him but I'm
he said oh come on come over here
hang on a minute he said sir Ringo Sir
Patrick Sir Paul hey we've got the
Knights of the Round Table
[Applause]
[Music]
the picnic Panzer of course is Fan Art
and Sarah Pasco I know you have had that
Accolade of people sending you fan art I
mean yeah so I've got one piece and I
think fan art is a strong word
we've got a picture should we see it
first yes okay okay so it took me
it's actually it's worth saying that
it's all of you because it is me it is
right this is the the fan art of Sarah
Pasco
I think fan art is a very loose term is
I was given this at a gig in lieu of
payment
oh yeah
you've actually ran the gig had spent
too much at the bar
to pay me so he painted that yes after
being at the bar of me what are those
bits I just think they're just free
biscuits
[Laughter]
pictures of people who tattooed your
face on their body oh no I'm not there
yet
Monday yeah I get them in my Twitter
feed all the times guys who have whole
calves the calves or a picture of jewels
on their chest or wow Nick Fury people
love and now Tom middleston you have fan
off at such specific fan art this is a
lot yeah and does it all come for this
one scene it was it the first Thor movie
with the spear right right yeah
yes um there's a there's a scene in a
first Thor film where my I'm not trying
to attack Thor Chris Hemsworth as Thor
with a spear and jump in the air and he
Dodges out the way and I bring the spear
down and it wedges itself into the floor
and then I use the use it to spin myself
around and kick him in the chest
which has been interpreted by fans as
um a demonstration of my hidden talent
at pole dance pole dancer
yeah look yeah no activity there's so
much of this but this is just one
example of Loki really going for it on
the pole
all right
is that Japanese but that's what you
wear in the movies
I've seen it yeah that's Loki's outfit
yeah I've never I've not seen that one
oh really oh really oh we'll print it
out you can take it home
very quickly it is Oscar's weekend this
weekend and uh Ian would you mind
telling us the story about when you were
nominated for uh Gandalf oh yeah and you
had the the beads yeah
well the wet beads
uh the in in uh New Zealand where we
filmed Lord of the Rings uh
you you you if you're lucky when you
leave you're given a piece of green
stone carved and you wear it often
enough and your chances are you'll get
back to New Zealand that's the idea and
it will bring you a bit of luck so uh
when those films were nominated with
something like 20 Oscars uh on that
night everybody from New Zealand was
wearing the green stone that punami Echo
and and we're on the red carpet going
into the so I met Maggie Smith you know
what are you doing what are you here for
I said well
I said well Lord of the Rings oh yeah
she said what's that round your neck all
right so it's my poonami um I only know
poonami what's that fight I said well if
I wear it it'll it'll bring me luck and
uh
[Music]
and we went to our separate ways and you
know it lasts for three and a half or
four hours you know then oh yeah oh gosh
and at the end of course everyone else
wins the Oscar apart from you
and a bit dejected you're coming out
looking forward to a drink and you bump
into Maggie Smith and she points at you
and she said it didn't work
[Laughter]
[Applause]
did you make Carol Thatcher and now so
how much preparation goes into well
obviously you put a nose on
but what else goes on preparing for
carotouch
I should make up some [__] but then
I watched I'm a celebrity get me out of
here
but now but when you're playing it at
something like a detective do you do
like for a broad Church did you do
preparation
no
sorry
um David did and I could ask him
questions
it seems silly doubling up
to defend my actions
um I don't think my character spoke in
the same sort of
um rhythms as detectives so I thought
it'd be better if I didn't have that
influence
well Nick Frost is the lead guy and uh
he uh as a child and I'm his sister
that's it I'm his sister and um
and as children uh he was Salsa champion
and endless cups and awards and things
and we used to go off and do
competitions and I was a dance partner
and then something happened and his life
changed and sassa wasn't for him after
that moment and then cut to uh Nick
Frost present day
or whatever his character is called and
um he's called Bruce
people are applauding you I'm
remembering the names of people in your
own films
you film something
Nelson Mandela
yeah I know we know you're not into big
you're not a big preparation but you
must have had some dancers I was forced
to
um because I had to dance on screen so I
had to practice do you look good though
well there is as you know they have
people who actually can dance yeah who
uh because I can only spend three times
before I vomit so
but we do we do have a picture of you in
rehearsals where it doesn't look like
it's going that well
[Laughter]
that's the one that you're wearing like
a full sweatsuit and heels what's nice
to know is it wasn't always like that I
don't know they're like what was it what
did you perform you performed at a
seafood festival I mean which which [__]
show you want to know about
that time zone I think they wanted was
it crap I had a crab fest
you're not you're not performing in in
luxury you know venues wherever they
feel that they can build the stage and
make money is where you're going so
there was a crab fest
[Applause]
comedian Talent I was like all right
well you know I'm available
I don't know if you guys have ever tried
to tell a joke about people cracking
crabs
[Laughter]
[Applause]
literally the frustration that comes
from not being able to open a crabs and
if you're not funny at the same time
stuff that you hear I remember hearing a
woman an older lady who was like she was
cracking crabs because this is how you
crack
looking at me and she's like cracking
the crab and I tell a joke and a joke
doesn't work and I remember this lady
just going oh no
[Laughter]
I don't think I would much rather be
booed
the disappointment
from her voice in his own she said baby
it was like oh no baby
I have made a mistake with my choice of
life like I'm not doing it wrong I mean
you know look the the the hardship that
I went through has helped build me into
the person I am today where I can take
so much but I've been through it all I
was I was hitting the face with a
buffalo wings
[Applause]
there's no food
uh it was it was a it was actually a
male strip club that they shut down for
comedy for the first half so it was like
a bunch of it was ladies in there and
you know it's just supposed to be us
performing for these women that were
riled up first thing I got on stage when
they introduced me and this lady was
like pull it out I said hey
hey hey that's not me I'm not here today
I'm here to entertain these jokes
I know who's got kids that's the stuff I
start trying to merge into kid material
and there's one dude from the back I
just remember this dude from the back he
was like that's enough and he's just
threw a buffalo wing at me
hey man hit me hit me in the cheek a
little bit of sauce
right here buffalo sauce is hot sauce
I assumed that it was a woman with a
deep voice so I was like who threw it
who threw it because at the end of the
day I'm a man I'm a man first don't
disrespect me
he stood up he was like I did it and I I
contemplated just taking my clothes off
[Applause]
[Music]